so we're going to do a classic number
foul video where we talk about a number
and a property of that number today's
number
is 196. what's special
about 196. well we're going to do a
process
called reverse and add it's very simple
little game you can do
so we're going to take a number uh
what number shall we take give me a two
digit number
23 23 all right i'm going to reverse and
add
so i'm going to reverse the digits so
it's 32 and add them together and if i'm
correct it's 55
okay now i'm going to stop there because
this is a palindrome number so it's the
same forwards and back
and that's what i want to get to let's
see if i can do another number
maybe it will take a little bit longer
to get to a palindrome
uh what other number could we pick
let's pick a three digit number 254
if we add 452 so
706 so we haven't got a palindrome
number yet
so we might have to do that again so we
take the result
and apply it again plus 607
add that together what do we get
so one three one three uh it's not
palindrome yet might have to do another
step
question is how many steps is this going
to take so we add these together
hey eddie took a couple of steps four
four four four
will all numbers end up finally
or eventually with a palindrome uh
it turns out all two digit numbers do
end up in a palindrome
all three digit numbers
uh we're not so sure about in fact
the number 196
is the smallest number that we don't
know
if it ends in a palindrome or not when
you
repeat this process and we've tried
for a billion iterations we've done this
over and over and over more than a
billion iterations and still
it hasn't ended in a palindrome
will it ever a number that doesn't end
in a palindrome
it's called a la shrel number 196
appears to be a la shrell number appears
to be the smallest one
but we're not sure we don't know it's
not proved
we've just checked it a lot
so most numbers take three four steps
not very
not very long uh 89
89 is an interesting one it takes 24
steps
to finally get to be a palindrome number
i'm pausing in case brady says go on
then
in case brady made me do it i did make a
note of that
but uh i haven't i haven't quite
finished it yet but brady isn't going to
make me do it
ah i'll do it on screen for you
excellent fantastic because we would be
here for a long time it took me ages to
do this
196 might be one of these la shriel
numbers
are there any definite lush real numbers
there are no
definite the shell numbers we've got a
list of candidates
only now i'm told that in lower basis if
we talk about base two
and base three and base four you can
show
numbers that definitely go into one of
these loops or we'll never end up in a
palindrome
and it turns out that base 10 not only
is it the base we use in
day-to-day life but it's the smallest
interesting case
for this it's the smallest base that
we're not sure
if we can do it or not in the smaller
bases apparently
we have an answer yeah so 196 is the
smallest candidate
the next one is 295
the next one is 394
and it's 493 so they're not irregular
there's about every 100 or so
there's there's quite a few of these
maybe
some of them are le shrell numbers and
some of them might just
finally become
a palindrome at some great distance away
we don't know
the next one might be more obvious
because we started with 196.
its palindrome automatically
is one of these candidates as well and
so on and so on
yes we've checked 196 for billions of
iterations
the numbers get larger every time you do
it
the numbers are now something like 600
million
digits long the shroud numbers by the
way that name
la shrel let's write that down that
came from one of the investigators in
this problem
it's actually a kind of rough but not
quite anagram
of his girlfriend's name which is cheryl
oh cheryl strikes again why do we do
this
there's no application there like we do
this video for fun for the exercise for
the mental exercise
for the practice of it maybe
it turns out that if there's a proof the
proof might use
techniques that are deeper than the
problem looks on its surface
and we can apply those to serious
problems this problem
became kind of famous in the 1980s in
the community of hobbyist
microcomputer programmers so they were
using this to test out their
microcomputer programming skills
and so they would make these lists of
these
reverse and add algorithms they'd make
these lists
and of course all you need is when you
want to pass on the baton
or pass on the torch to the next person
you just need the last entry
or you just give them the last entry and
then they can carry on
the the process and that's what's
happened since the 80s
this process this baton has been passed
from person to person currently
we are on these huge numbers and still
it hasn't been resolved yet
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this number file video and
with over 180
000 titles in their library it is the
best place to go
for audio books and other spoken
materials now i'm an audible customer
myself i especially enjoy listening
when i'm out walking the dogs as i've
spoken about before or embarking on a
really long drive across the country
really makes the whole drive a lot more
enjoyable now various numberphile stars
have books on audible i'm going to put
some links to them in the video
description so you can check them out
or if you're after one with a very
numbery title you can read the one i'm
reading at the moment
which is 11 22 63.
it's a really interesting book by
stephen king about time travel
and also deals with the assassination of
john f kennedy
it also weighs in at over 30 hours long
unabridged so i'm getting plenty of dog
walks out of that one
now if you're interested in checking out
audible and you really should
go to audible.com number file
then they'll know you came from here and
that's good and when you sign on
you get a free audio book at the start
so you get your first one for free you
can see what you think of the whole
thing
it's a great service as i said i use it
myself and importantly
thanks to them for supporting us here on
number five